well it was major news to fans of the
scream franchise when it was announced
that the fifth movie is
officially a go yes apparently ghostface
is
alive and well and it's much to the
delight of deputy dewey himself
david arquette oh my gosh i'm growing
the mustache out as we speak
hopefully it happened soon courtney cox
signed up we're waiting on nef campbell
she's the heart and soul of the scream
franchise so
to get nav would be a really tremendous
thing
of course et has been on the set of
every screen film
including 1997 sequel screen 2 when
david and courtney had just
started dating all right come on
what's it gonna be like for you and
courtney to work together again this is
amazing
well we co-parents so we're in touch
quite a bit
and it's great but we always love
working together that's such a good
point you co-parent
co-starring is nothing yeah star is the
easy part
will we get those bangs she's posted on
social media
the bangs were my fault i have to admit
i
i was like oh you should do a like a
betty page thing
is she glad that you suggested that or
do we all wish that it never happened
we all wish that would never happen
while we wait for scream five david is
keeping us entertained with his latest
thriller spree
stranger things star joe kiri plays his
son who kills
rideshare customers on camera all to get
social media likes
hello dude get in the car i'm in a hurry
plastic
really did you learn more about social
media
and followers and engagement and all
that than you did before
a little bit i learned a little bit
about social media but i'm still
completely lost coco i was talking to
her about tick tock and i just didn't
understand like what is tick tock
and she's like it kind of helps expand
her sense of humor she said
first place there's the line in the
movie it's if you're not
documenting yourself you just don't
exist and
especially being a parent what's your
philosophy you know i've always been
such an
open book with my life it's really hard
for me to give advice about
you know being subtle
you